The joe rogan experience.
Think about how much of our lives are influenced,
how much of our society is built on services that bring pleasure to our senses.
Our sense of touch.
We can go,
you go get a massage.
Damn right.
You can know the right place.
Our,
our sense of taste there is food brought to its high cuisine,
right?
Our sense of hearing.
Sure.
We,
we make beautiful music,
our sense of sight.
We make great art.
So much of what we do is to satisfy our five traditional senses.
Imagine if we had 10 sensors or 20.
I have a theory on that.
It's called the fart principle.
I have no understanding of how that principal could relate to this,
but I'm all ears.
This is why,
um,
if you did not have a nose and you could live your whole life without a sense of
smell in the year 2012,
it's very possible if you'd,
if someone foreign in front of you,
you'd have no idea that this terrible gas is,
you're inhaling,
it's in your note.
You wouldn't have that sense of smell.
So you could exist and not have any idea because gas is invisible.
Okay.
That's a bad example and I'll tell you why.
No,
no.
I'll tell you why.
It could be alien life form all around us all the time that we don't have the
sense to like,
it's like worms can't see,
but we can.
So to the two things,
so first,
uh,
it's a,
it's a good example in the sense that no pun intended in the sense of that
without,
if who knows what senses were missing and therefore who knows what there is to
measure in our world around us that we are completely missing.
Right.
All right.
Get back to that in a minute.
Regarding your fart theory.
Yes.
Here's the problem.
All right.
The,
my theories of for a peer review,
it is totally getting peer reviewed.
The good life.
It's the right thing to call it too.
It's a legitimate hypothesis.
Thank you.
It's out on the table now.
Here you go.
You're ready.
It's my life's work.
One of the active ingredients in the smell of a fart is hydrogen sulfide.
It turns out hydrogen sulfide is extremely lethal.
Is One of the most lethal gasses that exists.
Well,
why do we have such a good sense of smell for that?
Why don't we smell other gay?
Why don't we smell nitrogen?
Well,
we don't need to smell nitrogen because it's not going to kill us because it's
78% of what you breathe.
Anyway.
[inaudible] we have evolved a hypersensitive sense for the smell of hydrogen
sulfide.
If,
if,
if there was a gender,
if you gave birth to someone who said,
hydrogen sulfide smells beautiful and let's smell more of it,
let's get canisters of it.
They're dead.
10 minutes later,
no longer able to propagate the gene that liked the smell of hydrogen sulfide.
We had to not like that smell.
Otherwise we would not have survived.
The,
uh,
by the way,
hydrogen sulfide is a byproduct of the,
the digestive activity of anaerobic microbes.
That's why it comes out of your lower intestine with not only where the sun
don't shine,
where oxygen doesn't exist,
the microbes to thrive down there.
They are an aerobic and hydrogen sulfide is one of their byproducts.
It has been theorized that there have been places and times on earth where the
ocean currents stopped and when ocean current stop oxygen at the surface of the
ocean never makes it to the bottom.
So you can't sustain oxygen life forms at the bottom of the ocean.
There are no fish,
there wouldn't be any fishes down there if the ocean currents stopped because
the ocean currents not only go from one place to another in the world they
circle,
they circulate top to bottom.
All right,
so it's a two dimensional thing going on in three dimensions actually.
So,
so if something happens on earth where you stop the oceanic cycles,
you can create a condition in the lower ocean,
we're anaerobic lifeforms thrive.
If they thrive,
they out gas and one of the out gases is hydrogen sulfide.
It will gurgle up from the bottom of the ocean,
rise up near the shores,
turning shorelines into the smell of cesspools.
If you were alive at the time and didn't run away from that,
you would have simply died from it.
That is all well and good.
Therefore the nose,
the nose theory that if we didn't have a nose,
we could all just fart and we didn't have a nose.
We wouldn't have noticed hydrogen sulfide and humans would not have survived it
and some other creature would be having this interview right now.
I not gree with you and disagree with you at the same time.
It's a,
here's why what you're saying involves real people and real life adaptation to
our environment.
What I'm talking about is aliens that are just like farts.
That's why so you gave me a crazy long winded,
really an in depth explanation,
but you still don't discredit the possibility that just like the sense of smell,
it exists,
but it is invisible.
There could be many things around us that are also invisible,
but we have not developed any means to detect down.
Okay.
You were being metaphor.
She works right.
Wifi.
Why?
But he was a bit swing.
So you being metaphorical with your father sang live.
No one would have had to have a nose.
I overanalyze it down.
That was cool.
It was cool.
Oh,
by the way,
one global warming scenario is the yes.
You see the day after tomorrow.
Did you see that?
Unbelievably horrible.
Yeah.
That one was,
was that went to no clothes.
So good.
Who was bad when there was the cancer baby and everybody else is dead outside,
but there she's surviving with the cancer baby and she's going to stay there for
the kid.
We,
while 100 billion people are dead.
It's an awesome,
let me get back to your nose.
Your partner crazy.
Now,
here's why.
You're probably not right.
Well,
I'm definitely not right.
Look,
it's a ridiculous idea.
No,
no,
no.
But there's a reason why you're probably not.
Right.
Okay.
Because beginning in the 16 hundreds,
we learned that our senses are not only,
they not only fool us,
they and occasionally don't work.
They're not all that the universe tells us is they are not,
they don't have the capacity to recognize all that's going on in the universe.
Well,
certainly on a microscopic level.
that's my point.
That's my point.
So in the early 16 hundreds to the important advances,
uh,
actually late 1500 you had the invention of the microscope and you had the
invention of the telescope.
This is really the first steps to enhance our senses beyond what our human
biology in doubt us with.
And upon doing so,
we discovered things about the world that were previously oblivious to us.
We discovered,
knows farts when you wouldn't leave.
When hoke brought his telescope and his microscope to up drop of pond water and
saw what we were called Anna macules.
What else were you going to call it?
The little things,
paramecium had protozoa thriving in a drop of water.
That was a nose for it.
Keeping with your vocabulary.
That was something that previously no one had any idea was there.
And my point is,
beginning in 1600 and with an ever improving march forward,
the methods and tools of science have served to enhance our senses,
increase our senses,
increased the range of our senses,
but more importantly,
give us whole kinds of senses that your five senses could have never even
imagined that our human biology couldn't even approximate.
So as so,
so what's an example?
Um,
yeah.
Uh,
we don't have senses to detect magnetic field at all.
That's why you can sit in a Mri Chamber and sit there and you know,
whistle Dixie and you'll have no idea the strength of the magnetic field that's
being cast across your body.
We don't have sensors for it.
You don't have sensors for radio?
Well,
we're radio waves.
What the,
the difference there is we do have sensors for one aspect of the electromagnetic
spectrum.
We have sensors for infrared,
visible and a delayed since for ultraviolet.
Does that mean?
Oh Wow.
Sorry about that.
That's pretty loud.
And creative ringtone.
Just like mine,
I learned that aren't dangerous.
He goes old school.
Yeah.
Uh,
so,
uh,
so the point is the radio waves are part of the entire electromagnetic spectrum.
We,
we have access to some of that and we call that for obvious reasons.
Visible light,
right?
But outside of the range of visible light,
you have ultraviolet x rays,
gamma rays,
radio waves,
microwaves.
So yes,
we can't see radio waves,
but that would just be an extension of our senses in the way.
Jordy in Star Trek,
the next generation had his visor though that visor allowed him to see the
entire school star track on.
I got it.
I had to go there just because I had uh,
and my sideburns or star Trek sideburns.
I don't know if he,
uh,
so he puts the,
well he,
that visor enabled him to see the entire electromagnetic spectrum.
If we were thusly equipped,
you'd walk down the street and the microwave towers would be ablaze with
microwaves and you tune into sort of ultraviolet.
And if you,
you'd think twice about going to the beach because that's the stuff that gives
you skin cancer,
especially people with lighter skin.
If you,
if,
um,
if you want to see,
uh,
what would it be?
A good example if you want to see if there's a burglar entering your house,
just shift over to infrared.
If the burglar is warm blooded,
they will show up even if all the lights around like the Predator.
Uh,
exactly,
exactly.
It's another way to detect the light.
So,
so we have,
so science has broadened our senses and given a sense is that our human biology
could not have even thought of or invented.
So the notion at this day and age that something is happening on this tabletop
that is eluding us,
I think is just simply unlikely because we're so good now at finding things that
previously,
uh,
escaped our notice right in front of us right now.
That frontier is that the energy extremes of the cern accelerator in
Switzerland,
that frontier is at the James Webb space telescope where we're going to look at
the earliest formation of matter in the history of the universe.
These are the extremes of our measurements of nature today.
[inaudible]
you're a fucking human being.